I'm Jenna Fisher. And I'm Angela Kinsey. We were on The Office together. And we're best friends. And now we're doing the Ultimate Office rewatch podcast just for you. Each week we will break down an episode of The Office and give exclusive behind-the-scenes stories that only two people who were there can tell you. We're The Office, ladies. Hello. Hey there. Welcome, everyone, to this little bonus episode. Just throwing a little episode out there on a Friday for you. Yeah. Happy bonus Friday. So, you know, earlier this week we broke down the movie Speed. And we mentioned how very excited we were to get to talk to someone who was in the movie, who was on
我是珍娜·费舍尔。我是安吉拉·金西。我们一起出演过《办公室》。我们是好朋友。现在我们专门为你制作了《办公室》重温播客终极版。每周我们都会剖析一集《办公室》，并分享只有身临其境的两个人才能告诉你的独家幕后故事。女士们，我们是《办公室》。你好。大家好。欢迎各位收听这期精彩的小番外。周五特意为大家奉上这么一集。耶。祝大家周五番外快乐。所以呢，本周早些时候我们剖析了电影《生死时速》。我们提到过，能采访到一位参演过这部电影、并且就在那辆车上的演员，我们感到非常兴奋。
the bus. You know her as Dwight's babysitter from the dinner party. We know her as Beth Grant. And we got to talk to her about her time on that bus. That's right. Beth Grant is here. Speed fans will remember her as Helen, the nervous passenger who tries, you know, to get off the bus too early and does not go so well. No, she gets blown up. I know. Well, we were super curious what life was like on that bus with Keanu and Sandra and the rest of the cast. And you guys, Beth does not disappoint. She has great stories about her time on Speed. Yes. And you know, we thought about putting her interview in our Speed Breakdown, but
你认识她是《晚宴》里德怀特的保姆。我们认识她是贝丝·格兰特。我们得以采访她在那辆车上的时光。没错。贝丝·格兰特来了。《生死时速》的粉丝会记得她是海伦，那个神经质的乘客，你知道的，她试图过早下车，结果不太妙。不，她被炸飞了。我知道。好吧，我们对基努、桑德拉以及其他演员在那辆车上的生活充满了好奇。各位，贝丝没有让人失望。她有关于《生死时速》拍摄期间的精彩故事。是的。而且你知道的，我们曾考虑把她的采访放在我们的《生死时速》剖析节目中，但是
frankly, it stands alone. Yeah. It is its own thing. We hope you enjoy it. So, here it is, our conversation with Beth Grant. Beth Grant, here you are on Office, ladies. Oh, there you are. I can see you. We are so excited to have you here. We're such big fans of yours. I mean, everyone that watches the office knows you from dinner party. You are Dwight's babysitter and his date to the dinner. Oh, my God. How much fun did we have doing that episode? I mean, so much fun. It was so hard. Well, for me, I really thought I was going to lose it a couple of times. I mean, big time.
坦白说，它独立成篇了。是的。它独具一格。希望你们会喜欢。那么，这就是我们与贝丝·格兰特的对话。贝丝·格兰特，欢迎来到《办公室女士》。哦，你在那儿。我能看见你。很高兴你能来。我们是你的超级粉丝。我是说，所有看《办公室》的人都从《晚宴》中认识你。你是德怀特的保姆，也是他去晚宴的女伴。哦，天哪。拍那一集我们玩得有多开心？我是说，太开心了。太难了。对我来说，我真的以为有几次我要笑场了。我是说，非常严重。
When I was at the door carrying the cooler, I had just worked with Steve in Little Miss Sunshine. And so, you know, we knew each other a little bit. And I don't know, I felt like he was really trying to get me because the things he was improvising at the door, I, and I was so nervous because, you know, guest stars, you've guest stars. I mean, you don't know, you're, it's not your team, you know, and you don't know, you don't want to be bad. And I was holding and he kept saying these things. And I finally just went way down like this. And he said, Oh, great. Now she's crying. Anyway, we were off to a good start. And it was just the most fun. I
当我拿着冷藏箱走到门口时，我刚和史蒂夫合作过《阳光小美女》。所以，你知道的，我们俩有点熟。而且我不知道，我觉得他真的在试图整我，因为他在门口即兴发挥的东西，我，我当时太紧张了，因为你知道，客串演员，你们有客串演员。我是说，你不知道，你，这不是你的团队，你知道的，你不知道，你不想表现得很差。我当时拿着东西，他一直说那些话。我最后直接蹲下去了，像这样。他说：“哦，太好了。现在她哭了。”总之，我们开局不错。这绝对是最有趣的一次。我
love you guys so much. It was a very, very, very special memory. It is. I mean, you have to look at it from our point of view, too, which is that we're on the other side of the door and the door would start closed and it would just open on you holding a cooler, bringing a cooler to a dinner party. It was so hard not to laugh. Giant glasses. Yes. Every time you nod on that, you had a beat. I was sucking on a beat. But you know, rain cracked me up. And he kept grunting while he was eating his beats. Yeah. Most of us just love those beats. He's going mm, mm, mm. Like it's the best thing he's ever tasted. So funny. But all of you
太爱你们了。这是一段非常、非常、非常特殊的记忆。确实。我是说，你也得从我们的角度来看，那就是我们在门的另一边，门一开始是关着的，然后突然打开，你拿着一个冷藏箱，带着冷藏箱来参加晚宴。要忍住不笑太难了。巨大的眼镜。是的。你每次吃甜菜，都有一个节拍。我在吮吸一个甜菜。但你知道，雷恩把我逗笑了。他吃甜菜时一直发出呼噜呼噜的声音。是的。我们大多数人都很喜欢那些甜菜。他一直在“嗯，嗯，嗯”。就像那是他吃过最好吃的东西一样。太搞笑了。但你们所有人
guys were so funny. It was just the most bizarre, demented episode, really. Steve's sleeping on the little thing at the foot of the bed or having what she had three bedrooms to herself. Yeah. Exactly. Well, we are so thrilled to have you here today, and we are going to talk with you about your time on the movie speed. Yeah. We are super fans of speed. Can you believe that we're coming up on the 30th anniversary? I can't. 30 years ago, you were on that bus. Isn't that crazy? It's really nuts that time goes by so quickly. My daughter was not yet one year old. It was the first job that I had. I was on a series when she
都太搞笑了。这真的是最诡异、最变态的一集。史蒂夫睡在床尾的小架子上，或者她一个人占了三个卧室。没错。好吧，我们今天非常高兴能邀请到你，我们将和你聊聊你参演电影《生死时速》的时光。是的。我们是《生死时速》的超级粉丝。你能相信我们即将迎来30周年纪念日吗？我不敢相信。30年前，你在那辆公交车上。是不是很疯狂？时光飞逝，真是太疯狂了。我女儿当时还不到一岁。那是我有的第一份工作。我女儿出生时
was born, but it's very different to do a sitcom and to do a feature. Mm hmm. You know, and I thought that all of the bus stuff would be CGI. I didn't know we're going to be on live freeway and that my trailer was going to be, you know, a mile and a half, two miles, and I wouldn't be able to see my daughter. And I didn't want her stuck under a freeway, stuck in a, you know, so it was a painful experience in that way, being away from her. And, you know, I was still breastfeeding. Too much information, I know, but I would leave the house at 5 30 and drive crying all the way, you know, leaving my baby asleep. And then I wouldn't get home until 7 30 because
我正参演一部剧集，但拍情景喜剧和拍电影长片是完全不同的。嗯哼。你知道，我以为车上的戏份都是CGI特效。我不知道我们要在一个还在通车的公路上拍摄，而且我的房车会在一英里半、两英里外，我见不到我的女儿。我不想让她被困在高架桥下，被困在，你知道的，所以从离开她这一点来说，这是一段痛苦的经历。而且，我当时还在喂母乳。我知道这信息量有点大，但我早上5点半离开家，一路开车一路哭，你知道的，把熟睡的宝宝留在家里。然后直到7点半我才能回家，因为
we had, you know, 12 hour days. And where did you pump in my little trailer? I mean, I would say it wasn't painful. I could wait for those breaks when we got to go back. But for a lot of the time, we couldn't even go back to our trailers. We were on the freeway with an umbrella that was kind of it. This was one of my big questions because like, how did bathroom breaks work? We use porta potties. Oh, they would have like stopping points, but they weren't those fancy little porta potties. There were construction workers literally on the 105. It hadn't quite opened. It was live. There were there were, you know, construction workers, cars
我们有，你知道的，12小时的工作制。你在哪里挤奶？在我的小房车里？我是说，我也不会说这有多痛苦。我可以等着那些能回去的休息时间。但很多时候，我们甚至不能回房车。我们就呆在高速公路上，只有一个伞，差不多就是这样。这是我的一个大问题，因为，上厕所是怎么解决的？我们用流动厕所。哦，他们会有那种停靠点，但它们不是那种fancy的小流动厕所。105号公路上真的有建筑工人。它还没完全开通。它是通车的。那里有，你知道的，建筑工人，有车
going by and so on. And there were real construction workers. And so they had to have porta potties. So I think our porta potties, they probably just incorporated them. Okay. So other than porta potties, there was really nothing there. Everything we see the film crew added, right? We had 300 cars that were extras cars, which let me tell you something. You don't want to miss a line when they have to turn around 300 cars. But it was just one of those things, knowing that there are helicopters going around and 300 cars and yonder bot, you know, love him maniac. He's got all this stuff going on. I mean,
开过去等等。那里真的有建筑工人。所以他们必须有流动厕所。所以我想我们的流动厕所，他们可能只是顺便借用了。好吧。所以除了流动厕所，那里真的什么都没有。我们看到的一切都是电影剧组后期加上去的，对吧？我们有300辆车作为群众演员的车，让我告诉你们一件事。当他们不得不掉头300辆车时，你可千万不能忘词。但这就是那种情况，知道有直升机在周围盘旋，有300辆车，还有亚当·波特，你知道的，那个狂热分子。他有各种各样的状况发生。我是说，
we were shooting with 11 cameras. We had cameras on the wheels, you know, cameras all over the bus. We had cameras. I mean, crazy. But one time to my mortification, I have, you know, quite an angular face. And it was Sandy's closeup. And my nose apparently kept popping in and out. And my nose in my chin. And finally they had to stop 300 cars, turn around hell. I mean, it's like it wasn't subtle when you messed up. It was not. Everybody knew. And you could hear the going again, going again, turn around. It was horrible. But we made it. And we didn't mess up too much, you know. Well, I have a question for you, Beth.
我们是用11台摄像机在拍摄。我们在车轮上装了摄像机，你知道的，摄像机装满整辆公交车。我们有摄像机。我是说，太疯狂了。但有一次令我感到无比羞愧的是，我有，你知道的，一张轮廓分明的脸。那是桑迪的特写。而我的鼻子显然一直在画面里进进出出。我的鼻子和我的下巴。最后他们不得不叫停300辆车，掉头。我的意思是，当你搞砸时，这可不是不显眼的。非常明显。所有人都知道。你能听到他们在喊“再来一次，再来一次，掉头”。太糟糕了。但我们做到了。而且我们也没有搞砸太多，你知道的。好吧，我有一个问题想问你，贝丝。
What was the audition process like? Like, what was the scene you auditioned with? And it seems like you didn't know you were going to be on an actual bus. I didn't. Well, it was John DeBond. And I had worked with him before on Flatliners that Joel Schumacher directed. And so I knew he was really a great DP. You know, of course, he had done Die Hard, big, big movies. But I liked him, you know, he's crazy. I mean, he's like me. He's like, in fact, Sandy, he and Sandy and I really had fun. I think we probably drove people crazy because we cracked a lot of jokes and we were naughty Sandy and I quite often.
试镜过程是怎样的？比如，你试镜的时候演的是哪场戏？而且听起来你当时并不知道自己要在真正的公交车上拍戏。我不知道。嗯，那是扬·德邦特。我以前和他合作过乔尔·舒马赫导演的《别惹子弹》。所以我知道他真的是个很棒的摄影指导。当然，你知道的，他拍过《虎胆龙威》这种超级大片。但我喜欢他，你知道的，他很疯狂。我是说，他就像我一样。他就像，事实上，桑迪，他和桑迪以及我真的玩得很开心。我想我们可能把大家逼疯了，因为我们开了很多玩笑，我和桑迪经常一起调皮捣蛋。
And so the three of us got along really great. And but anyway, so the audition process. And it was John and I read the script and I thought a bus, you know, going 50, 50 miles an hour. If it got, you know, it just seemed preposterous to me. And I called my friend Don Mancini, who wrote the child's play movies. And Don, we were very close at that time. And he really knew Hollywood. I mean, he knew what movies were happening. He read all the scripts. He had a real good sense of what was going to happen, what wasn't going to happen. So I called him, I said, yeah, I've got this audition. What do you think? He's, oh, do it, do it. It's a huge movie. This is going to be huge. I said, really? People want to watch a
所以我们三个相处得非常融洽。不过总之，试镜过程。那是扬和我一起读剧本，我想象着一辆公交车，你知道的，开到50英里每小时。如果它，你知道的，这对我来说似乎太荒谬了。我打电话给我的朋友唐·曼奇尼，他写过《鬼娃回魂》系列电影。当时我和唐非常亲密。他真的很了解好莱坞。我是说，他知道哪些电影正在筹备。他读过所有的剧本。他对什么会发生、什么不会发生有一种很好的直觉。所以我打电话给他，我说，嘿，我有个试镜。你觉得怎么样？他说，哦，去吧，去吧。这是一部超级大片。这会大火的。我说，真的吗？人们会想看一辆
runaway bus? Absolutely. Do it, do it. So I read the script, which was not the script you saw, by the way, different script. Graham Yo's script was very different after Joss Whedon did the rewrite. Yeah, that's what we're learning. And it's a lot of fun stuff that changed, you know, but it was a really nice role at that time. It wasn't what ended up being in the script, but it was sort of like the Poseidon adventure or Towering Inferno. We all had these backstories and history. And I liked my character. She had just gotten engaged. She had a little dog. She had, she and Sandy's character were friends. I had been to see her do stand up the night before. So it was all, you know, chatty. And then they would, every bus stop, they would stop and the
失控的公交车吗？绝对的，去吧，去吧。所以我读了剧本，顺便说一句，那不是你看到的剧本，是不同的剧本。乔斯·韦登重写后，格雷厄姆·约的剧本发生了很大变化。是的，这就是我们正在了解的。有很多有趣的东西都改了，你知道的，但当时这是一个非常不错的角色。它不是最终出现在剧本里的那个角色，但它有点像《海神号历险记》或《火烧摩天楼》。我们都有这些背景故事和过往。我喜欢我的角色。她刚订婚。她有一只小狗。她和桑迪的角色是朋友。我前一天晚上刚去看过她表演单口喜剧。所以一切都是，你知道的，很健谈的。然后他们会，在每个公交车站，他们会停下来，
people would come on and you would kind of find out more about them, you know. And so that was the script that I read. And so anyway, I just cut loose and had fun. And in the script, I was the hero. The bus driver actually had a heart attack in that script. And I was the one that came forward and did CPR and saved his life. And then I was the one who volunteered to get off the bus first to sort of test the waters. And we did all that. And I got on my knees in the audition and I was doing CPR. I mean, I just went for it. So it was really fun. I really loved it. And I really, you know, hoped I would get it by the time I left. And, but then as it happens in Hollywood, we were shooting like the day after Labor Day. And we went to, we had a reading,
人们会上车，然后你会对他们有更多了解，你知道的。这就是我读到的剧本。所以不管怎样，我就放开自我，玩得很开心。在剧本里，我是英雄。在那份剧本里，公交车司机实际上心脏病发作了。而我是那个冲上前去进行心肺复苏并救了他一命的人。然后我是那个自愿第一个下车去探路的人。我们把这些都演了。我在试镜时跪在地上做心肺复苏。我是说，我全力以赴了。所以真的很有趣。我真的很喜欢它。而且我真的，你知道，希望在我离开时能得到这个角色。但是，正如好莱坞常有的那样，我们将在劳动节的第二天开始拍摄。我们去进行了一次剧本围读，
a table read, and we had a costume parade. And so first I get there and your boyfriend, Keanu, sitting there all pumped up, baby. I mean, he looked good. And I was already a fan of his. I'd always thought, to me, he's underrated, underestimated. I just think he's a genius. He's so authentic and real and loving. And it always comes across. Anyway, he's sitting there, all pumped up, which I had never seen him like that. And I said, Oh, wow, you look great. This is really exciting. This is really good for you, huh? And he said, I hope so. He's just so real. So anyway, then we go in. So we get these new scripts. So I start going through the script and I said, huh. At the table read. It's the first time you've seen it. First time I've seen the
我们还试穿了戏服。所以首先我到了那里，你的男朋友基努，坐在那里，浑身肌肉，宝贝。我是说，他看起来状态极佳。我已经是他的粉丝了。我一直觉得，在我看来，他被低估了，被小看了。我只是觉得他是个天才。他是如此的真实、真诚和充满爱意。这种特质总是能透过银幕传递出来。不管怎样，他坐在那里，浑身肌肉，我以前从来没见过他那样。我说：“哦，哇，你看起来太棒了。这真的让人兴奋。这对你很有好处吧？”他说：“希望如此。”他就是这么真实。不管怎样，然后我们进去了。于是我们拿到了新剧本。所以我开始翻阅剧本，然后我说：“啊哈。”在围读剧本的时候。这是你第一次看到它。
rewrites. I think they were hot off the press. And I think, Oh my God, it's all her characters gone. There's no dog. I'm not engaged. I'm not friends with. I thought there's nothing here to do. I don't know what am I going to do? And so Sandy and I went to the same college. And she obviously younger than me. And when we had, they put out this directory of all the famous alumni, you know. And so I had a very nice little picture and a little nice bio. And then Sandy had this huge spread in the middle because she had done working girl, the series. And I thought, who the hell is that? You know, and this, this guy that wrote for the Raleigh Newsom Observer said, Oh, you need to meet her. You're going to love her. She's great. And gave me her phone number and said,
我第一次看到重写后的内容。我想它们一定是刚印出来的。我想，天哪，她的所有角色都被删了。没有狗了。我没有订婚了。我和她不是朋友了。我想这里面没有什么可演的了。我不知道，我要怎么办？所以我和桑迪上了同一所大学。她显然比我年轻。当时他们发布了一本所有杰出校友的名录，你知道的。所以里面有我一张非常好看的小照片和一份不错的简短生平。然后桑迪在中间占了很大一页，因为她演过情景喜剧《打工女郎》。我想，这到底是谁呀？你知道的，这个给《罗利新闻与观察家报》写稿的家伙说：“哦，你需要见见她。你会喜欢她的。她人很好。”并给了我她的电话号码，说，
call her up. Y'all will get along great. And I'm saying, I'm going to call her. I was jealous. But anyway, so we're sitting there. I just read this script and in walks Sandra Bullock, the girl from my college. And I was like, and then she turned. And this really happens. She, it makes me cry. She turned and she looked at me and her eyes lit up her face lit up and I fell in love. So Sandy comes over and she, you know, she's East Carolina, East Carolina, you know, Southern girls. So, you know, we were best friends for the whole shoot. And she saved my life because I had just read this script where my part was kind of gone. And then when we got on this set, when we went to rehearse first, then we read the script, she was fabulous. It was fabulous.
“给她打电话。你们俩会相处得很好的。”而我在想，我要给她打电话。我很嫉妒。但无论如何，我们坐在那里，我刚读完剧本，桑德拉·布洛克——我大学的那个女孩——走了进来。我当时就想，然后她转过身来。这真的发生了。她，这让我哭了。她转过身看着我，她的眼睛亮了，她的脸也亮了，我恋爱了。所以桑迪走了过来，你知道的，她是东卡罗莱纳的，东卡罗莱纳的，你知道的，南方女孩。所以，你知道的，我们在整个拍摄期间都是最好的朋友。她救了我的命，因为我刚刚读了那个剧本，我的戏份基本上都没了。然后当我们到了片场，当我们去排练时，我们读了剧本，她太棒了。简直太棒了。
It was different. It wasn't what I wanted to do, but it was great. We had the reading, then we went for our costume parade. And we did that. And then we got on the set. We put, they put us on a bus and we went to the 105 freeway for the rehearsal. And I'm looking. Wait, the rehearsal was on a moving bus as well? Yeah. I mean, you were first on a moving bus. Yes. But we didn't go 50. You know what I mean? Maybe we did for a minute. They were testing that. But mostly, yeah, we did. No. Yeah. And then we would all get out. Did anyone get car sick? Oh, what a funny question. Nothing I know of. Not that I know of. We did not. Maybe it's different on a bus than in a car.
它是不一样的。这不是我想演的，但它很棒。我们进行了围读，然后我们去试穿了戏服。我们完成了这些。然后我们上了片场。我们上了一辆公交车，然后去了105号高速公路进行排练。我看着。等等，排练也是在一辆行驶的公交车上吗？是的。我是说，你一开始是在一辆行驶的公交车上。是的。但我们没有开到50码。你知道我的意思吗？也许有一分钟开到了。他们在测试那个。但主要是，是的，我们确实开了。不。是的。然后我们都会下车。有人晕车吗？哦，多有趣的问题啊。据我所知没有。据我所知没有。我们没有。也许在公交车上和在轿车里感觉不一样吧。
Maybe we just scared. That's lucky though. That's lucky. Would you guys actually be in the bus when the bus was hitting things? I mean, we would crash into cars while you were in the bus. We did. I mean, sometimes just sometimes though, and I can't do which ones, but we were in it for a lot of it, you know, like that one where we hit all the water things, you know, we were in the bus for that. That was shot in Long Beach on an entrance and boom, boom, boom. And a lot of it was very real on the street, you know, with the baby carriage going. That was, we were all right there. It was scary. Yon is a nut. He likes to go for it.
也许我们只是被吓到了。不过这挺幸运的。这很幸运。当公交车撞击东西时，你们真的在公交车里吗？我是说，当你在公交车里时，我们会撞上汽车。我们确实撞了。我是说，有时候只是有时候，我不记得是哪些了，但大部分时间我们都在里面，你知道的，就像那场我们撞了所有水马的戏，你知道的，我们在公交车里。那是在长滩的一个入口处拍摄的，轰，轰，轰。而且很大一部分都是在街上非常真实的场景，你知道的，还有婴儿车经过。那就是，我们都在现场。很吓人。扬是个疯子。他喜欢动真格的。
Unfortunately, Sandy and Keanu and I are nuts. And, you know, Keanu did his, that stunt getting out of the Jag on to the bus, you know, on doing it. And once he did his stunt, then of course, Hawthorne James wanted to do his getting on the and so I said, well, I'm not going to let men do their I'll do mine. Here I am a new mother. I mean, and they had stunt women for me. They had, you know, two different stunt women there. They had said I had to do full body cast. So they had three or four of me. I mean, I was everywhere. Okay, we really want to ask you about that hard right turn when the bus has the 90 degree turn and he's like, everyone get on the other side. And, and it goes up on two wheels. Like,
不幸的是，桑迪、基努和我都是疯子。而且，你知道的，基努完成了他的那个特技动作——从捷豹车跳到公交车上，你知道的，他做到了。一旦他完成了他的特技动作，那么当然，霍桑·詹姆斯也想完成他上车的动作，所以我说，好吧，我不会让男人们独占特技的，我也要演我自己的。我当时是个新手妈妈。我是说，他们为我准备了特技替身。他们准备了，你知道的，两个不同的女特技演员在那里。他们说我必须制作全身石膏像。所以他们有三四个我。我是说，到处都是我。好吧，我们真的很想问你关于那个急转弯的事，当公交车做出90度转弯，他喊着“大家去另一边”，然后它单侧两轮着地时。就像，
were you on that bus when it did the hard right turn? We were, but I don't know. The two wheel thing might have been shot as a separate piece. We did it though. It was right there at the entrance of the 105 and the 110, I believe. So it wasn't actually, I think it was on a street rather than the actual ramp, I think. That's what it looks like. Yeah, it was. Yeah, it's real. So much of it is real. What Yon said to me, I wanted to quit when I saw that we were shooting on the freeway. And he said, trust me, I'm going to shoot this like a European film. You saw all the costumes were in earth tones. And he said, we got, we're going to cover this in a very specific way, like a European film and real, we're going to keep it real. And so I, you know, I took him at
你们车做急右转的时候你在那辆公交车上吗？我们在的，但我不知道。两轮行驶的那部分可能是分开拍的。不过我们确实拍了。我记得就在105号和110号公路的入口那里。所以其实不是在真正的匝道上，而是在一条街道上，我想。看起来是这样的。是的，确实是。是的，那是真的。很多都是真的。扬对我说过，当我看到我们要去高速公路上拍摄时，我都想不干了。他说，相信我，我要把这部片子拍得像一部欧洲电影。你看所有的服装都是大地色的。他说，我们要以一种非常具体的方式来拍摄，就像欧洲电影一样真实，我们要保持真实。所以，你知道的，我听信了
his word and I think that is what he did. Do you agree? Yeah, I have blown away by some of these shots that they got and where the cameras were mounted. And I was so tense in so many scenes because it feels so scary. Yeah, yeah, it is. It was real. Anything you saw on our faces was probably real. I have to imagine you guys really bonded being on the bus together for so long. I mean, how many weeks were you shooting? Well, I shot for six weeks. I think they shot for seven or eight after I died. Although Sandy had me come back. It was so funny. She wanted me off camera when she knows Helen's dead for Helen's death. Yeah. And so they call me up after I wrapped and they said, Sandy, you know, was wondering if you could maybe come back and do that. So of
他的话，我觉得他确实做到了。你同意吗？是的，他们拍的有些镜头以及摄像机安装的位置真的震撼到我了。在很多场景里我都感到非常紧张，因为感觉太吓人了。是的，是的，确实如此。那是真的。你在我们脸上看到的任何表情可能都是真的。我不得不想象你们在公交车上待了那么久，感情一定很深厚。我是说，你们拍了多少周？嗯，我拍了六周。在我死后他们大概又拍了七到八周。不过桑迪还让我回来了。太搞笑了。当桑迪知道海伦死了，也就是海伦死的时候，她想让我离开镜头。是的。所以在我杀青后他们给我打电话，说桑迪想知道你能不能回来拍那个。所以
course, you know, I was thrilled to go back. But anyway, I came back and so I'm in the bus and counter gets on the bus and he said, what are you doing here? You're dead. I said, off camera. Yeah. Have you stayed close with any of your bus mates after this experience? I know it's been 30 years, but yeah, Sandy's the only one. And since she is a very wonderful mother and very much engaged in her life, you know, as a mom, I haven't seen her as much. We've had some email exchanges, but I haven't seen her for a while. But we were very close for a long time. And, you know, I would still call her if I needed help. If I was something was going on and it was urgent, I wouldn't hesitate to call her. I love her. Now I know she would respond, you know, and I hope she
当然了，你知道的，能回去我超级兴奋。不过不管怎样，我回去了，所以我在车上，康纳上了车，他说，你在这干嘛？你死了。我说，不在镜头前。是的。经历过这次之后，你和车上的其他伙伴还有保持密切联系吗？我知道已经过去30年了，但是，是的，只有桑迪。而且既然她是一个非常棒的母亲，并且作为妈妈把很多精力都放在生活上，你知道的，我见她的次数就没那么多了。我们通过一些电子邮件，但我已经有一段时间没见她了。不过我们曾经很长时间里关系都非常好。而且，你知道的，如果我需要帮助，我还是会给她打电话。如果有什么急事发生了，我毫不犹豫就会打电话给她。我爱她。现在我知道她也会回应，你知道的，而且我希望她
knows that about me. So yeah, it was a lifelong friendship developed with her. That's so wonderful. Yeah. And so we were united on time to kill. And then she wrote during that period, she wrote a little short called Making Sandwiches. And she wrote a part, I don't know if she wrote it for me or if I just happened to be lucky and be there at the right time to play it, but we shot it and been to her a little short. I gave you Spencer's in it. Matthew McConaughey's in it. Me. Oh, Eric Roberts is in it. That's quite quite the cast for a short film. Yeah. It was a premiered at Sundance and, you know, wonderful little movie. Then when all about Steve came along, my agent wanted said, you need to get in there and play her mother. But it was written
对我也有所了解。所以，是的，我和她建立了一段终生的友谊。太棒了。是的。所以我们在《杀死的时间》里合作过。然后在那期间她写了一部名为《做三明治》的小短片。她写了一个角色，我不知道她是为我写的，还是我刚好很幸运、在对的时间出现在那里去扮演它，但我们把它拍了下来，成为了她的一部小短片。我记得斯宾塞在里面。马修·麦康纳在里面。我。哦，埃里克·罗伯ts也在里面。对于一部短片来说，这阵容可以说是相当强大了。是的。它在圣丹斯电影节首映了，你知道的，是一部非常棒的小电影。后来当《关于史蒂夫的一切》出现时，我的经纪人希望并说，你需要去那里演她妈妈。但剧本写得
as an agent Marilyn Monroe type. And I'm thinking, that's not my casting. But my agent was just like, I want you on that movie. And so she got me the audition. I said, okay, I'm going for it. And so I wore this pink fluffy dress, put on a blonde wig and went in and went for it. And then Sandy called me to tell me that I got it, that the studio approved me. And it was just thrilling to then go get to play her mom. We had the best time that we laughed so much. And it was so fun for me to play a character like that, because no one in the world would believe I would do it. But just goes to show you really need to go for it, you know, if you audition. I mean, if I had said offer only, or if I hadn't been willing to take a chance, you know, really,
像玛丽莲·梦露那样的金发尤物。而我想，这不适合我的戏路。但我的经纪人就觉得，我希望你参演那部电影。所以她帮我争取到了试镜机会。我说，好吧，我要去争取。于是我穿着这条粉红色的蓬蓬裙，戴上金色假发，去了并全力以赴。然后桑迪打电话告诉我我被选中了，工作室批准了我。然后能去演她的妈妈真是太令人兴奋了。我们度过了最美好的时光，我们笑得前俯后仰。对我来说，扮演这样一个角色真的太有趣了，因为世界上没有人会相信我会这么做。但这恰恰说明了如果你去试镜，你真的需要全力以赴，你知道的。我是说，如果我说只接片酬邀约，或者如果我不愿意冒险，你知道，真的，
they wouldn't have happened. So, Beth, you've done three films with Sandra Bullock. Plus, you were in her directorial debut and only film she's ever directed. So you've, you guys have worked together over these 30 years since speed four times in these different movies and have a lifelong friendship. Yeah. I mean, what a blessing, this movie. Yeah. Yeah, it is. It is. It's what you take with you. In the end, that's what it's all about. Yeah. Well, you know, she did me, I mean, she saved, I told her this, you know, she never wants to take credit for anything. She always compliments everybody else and is always so giving and loving. And but she saved my life on that movie. First of all, I don't know that I would have stayed on the movie once I saw that
这一切就不会发生了。所以，贝丝，你和桑德拉·布洛克合作过三部电影。另外，你还参演了她的导演处女作，也是她执导的唯一一部电影。所以自从《生死时速》以来的这30年里，你们在四部不同的电影中合作过，并且拥有终生的友谊。是的。我是说，这部电影真是一大福祉。是的。是的，确实如此。这是你最终能带走的东西。到头来，这才是最重要的。是的。嗯，你知道的，她对我有恩，我是说，她拯救了，我告诉过她这个，你知道的，她从不想把功劳归于自己。她总是称赞其他人，总是那么慷慨和充满爱心。但是她在电影里救了我的命。首先，我不知道一旦我看到那个东西，我还会不会留在剧组
thing. But I bonded with her. I loved her. You know, I felt like I wanted to work with her and Keanu and Jan gave me, but beyond that, she just was always upbeat and positive. She had such a good attitude. And we had chocolate break every day at I think four o'clock and they would bring out the chocolate. And I didn't even eat sugar at the time, but honey, I was eating Tootsie rolls. And we would dance if you can believe it. We would put on salsa music and she's a great dancer. And she would salsa dance, you know, my pitiful version of salsa dancing, but she kept everybody going. Like if it was because it was so hot and the hours were so long. And as I say, we couldn't even get to our trailers, all of that. But her attitude was so good and positive and loving at
但我跟她建立了深厚的感情。我爱她。你知道的，我觉得我想和她、基努以及扬一起工作，但除此之外，她总是那么乐观积极。她的态度太好了。我们每天下午四点左右都会有巧克力时间，他们会把巧克力拿出来。当时我甚至不吃糖，但天哪，我当时在吃托茨卷糖（Tootsie Rolls）。如果你敢相信的话，我们还会跳舞。我们会放萨尔萨舞曲，她是个绝佳的舞者。她会跳萨尔萨舞，你知道的，我有我那可怜版本的萨尔萨舞，但她让每个人都保持着活力。因为天气太热了，工作时间又那么长。正如我所说，我们甚至都去不了化妆车，诸如此类。但她的态度在任何时候都那么好、
all times that she kept me going. I mean, I made it because of her. And so I really feel like, you know, I owe her that forever. So while you were shooting it, you knew you knew this was going to be a hit. While you were making it, you guys felt it. You could feel you were part of something special. We could. I mean, also, it just felt good. You know, if Jan was on his game, the crew was on their game, Keanu, I could see was going to be an action star. It worked out pretty well. Sure did. Yeah. And you just could tell. And he was so sweet. Talk about bonding. Yeah. Can we talk a little bit about Keanu? Oh, my God, I want to tell you everything. One day in Long Beach, I guess it was the day in fact, we did that thing on the on ramp where
那么积极、那么充满爱，是她支撑着我坚持了下来。我是说，我能坚持下来全靠她。所以我觉得，你知道的，我永远亏欠她。所以在拍摄的时候，你就知道，你就知道这会成为一部热门电影。在拍摄的过程中，你们有这种感觉吗？你能感觉到你们是一部特别作品的一部分。我们能感觉到。我是说，而且感觉也很好。你知道的，如果扬状态在线，剧组状态在线，我就能看出基努会成为一名动作巨星。结果证明确实如此。确实如此。是的。而且你一眼就能看出来。他太甜了。说到建立感情。是的。我们能聊聊基努吗？哦，天哪，我想把一切都告诉你。在长滩的那天，我想事实上就是我们在上坡匝道上
we ran into the water barrels. Sure. That was what we were shooting. There's a lot of technical stuff to work out. So we had a lot of downtime on the streets of Long Beach. And so we made up a comedy show that would be called Sandy Sandy, kind of cute, kind of wild Sandy. And and then we he would be the boyfriend. And I don't know, I think I was making it up and he was acting it out. And he fell on the grass and kicked like a cockroach and just did I mean, just cute, funny stuff that you don't really see that side of him, you know, very often in interviews or in what he does, but just cute, sweet, funny, going with whatever crazy game we were coming up with. And just such a team player with this cast. That sounds so charming. I feel like we were
撞上水桶的那天。没错。那就是我们在拍的。有很多技术问题需要解决。所以在长滩的街道上，我们有很多空闲时间。于是我们编了一个喜剧节目，叫做“桑迪·桑迪，有点可爱，有点狂野的桑迪”。然后他演男朋友。我不知道，我想是我在编，他在表演。他倒在草地上，像个蟑螂一样踢腿，就是做出——我是说，就是那种可爱搞笑的举动，你不会经常在采访中或他的作品中看到他那一面，但就是那种可爱、甜蜜、搞笑的举动，配合着我们想出的任何疯狂游戏。而且在这个演员阵容中，他真的是个极好的团队合作者。听起来太迷人了。我觉得我们
like that on the set of the office, Jenna, how we would get punchy being in the conference room. Listen, it wasn't a moving bus. We didn't have to hang out on the side of a freeway. But we definitely had all of these little comedy bits we would do and and act out and be silly and kept us going throughout like long days on set. That's why it worked. You know, you can feel it on that show. You really can. I mean, your show and that show. But you can, you can feel it. It just couldn't have worked any other way. I love the idea of thinking that Keanu does bits. Exactly. Beth, I have to know, was there ever like a stunt that went wrong for a second? Were there any mishaps that you remember? Or was it all pretty controlled?
在《办公室》剧组时也是这样的，珍娜，我们在会议室里累到语无伦次时就是这样。听着，那可不是一辆移动的公交车。我们不需要挂在高速公路边上。但我们确实有所有这些我们经常做的小喜剧片段，进行表演，然后发挥搞怪精神，支撑我们度过片场漫长的一天。这就是为什么它行之通。你知道的，你在那部剧里能感受到这一点。你真的能。我是说，你的剧和那部剧。但你可以，你能感觉到。它不可能以任何其他方式奏效。我太喜欢基努也会演喜剧小品这个想法了。没错。贝丝，我必须知道，有没有过哪个特技在一瞬间出了差错？你还记得有什么意外吗？还是说一切都在控制之中？
I can't remember anything going wrong, except, you know, maybe my acting. Oh, no. My whining. I tell you, I went to that premiere and I thought, get that lady off the bus with her whining. What about the rest of us? Why about the rest of us? You know, Jan said to me, I asked him, I said, why aren't I the hero anymore? So we have too many heroes. He said, we need Richard Chamberlain in Towering in front of, we need a coward. So I was the coward. But in the original script, Jeff Daniels was the bad guy. Yes. Isn't that shocking? Yeah. No, he was in cahoots. Yeah. It was really good. It was, I like. Do you like that twist? I did. But I also thought that it was very moving when he died in our version.
我不记得有什么地方出错了，除了，你知道的，可能我的演技。哦，不。我的抱怨。我告诉你，我去参加首映式时心想，把那个满嘴抱怨的女人从车上弄下去。那我们其他人呢？我们其他人呢？你知道的，扬对我说，我问他，我怎么不再是英雄了？所以我们有太多英雄了。他说，我们需要《摩天大楼失火记》里的理查德·张伯伦站在……前面，我们需要一个懦夫。所以我就是那个懦夫。但在最初的剧本里，杰夫·丹尼尔斯是个坏人。是的。是不是很震惊？是的。不，他是同谋。是的。真的很不错。是的，我很喜欢。你喜欢那个转折吗？是的。但我也觉得当他在我们的版本里死时，非常感人。
Me too. I did think that worked very well because that second on his face when he knows he's going to die. Oh my God. And who doesn't love Jeff Daniels? Yeah, you know what's crazy after I watched that scene and I saw that moment of realization in his eyes after he sees the red light. I watched it several times and then I tried to do it as an acting exercise. I did too, too. I was like, am I a good enough actor that I could do Jeff Daniels' moment of realization? It was so good. So I tried it. It was so funny. I did the same thing. I said, could I do that? Would it look real? Do I look like a cartoon? Yes. It was so, because it was so good. Well, I'm proud of you guys. Those are real actors that would do that. You saw a great moment and you
我也是。我确实觉得那段拍得很好，因为当他看到红灯、意识到自己要死的那一刻，他脸上的那个表情。哦，天哪。谁能不爱杰夫·丹尼尔斯呢？是的，你知道最疯狂的是什么吗？看完那场戏后，在他看到红灯后眼里闪过那一瞬间的领悟时，我看了好几遍，然后我把它当作表演练习来尝试。我也试过，我也试过。我在想，我是不是一个足够优秀的演员，能够演出杰夫·丹尼尔斯那种顿悟的时刻？太棒了。所以我尝试了一下。太搞笑了。我也做了同样的事。我说，我能做到吗？看起来会真实吗？我看起来像个卡通人物吗？是的。太棒了，因为实在太精彩了。好吧，我为你们骄傲。只有真正的演员才会这样做。你看到了一个精彩的时刻，然后你
wanted to see if you could duplicate it and I have no doubt that you wouldn't good. That's great. My well little cartoony. I'm no Jeff Daniels. I'll say that. But my goodness, it's crazy though, because so many people in the film did not get to work together. Like, you never got to work with Jeff Daniels. You never got to work with Dennis Hopper. Dennis Hopper was by himself for most of the movie. On a telephone. But you know, one thing that I did notice on the bus, which just blew my mind, is how you've got, you know, the police captain and all the police officers are on like a flatbed next to the bus. And there are all these scenes where they are just the background of something that's happening on the
想看看自己能不能复制它，我毫不怀疑你一定能做到。太棒了。我嘛，稍微有点像卡通片。我可不是杰夫·丹尼尔斯。我得这么说。但天哪，这太疯狂了，因为片中很多人根本没有机会一起合作。比如，你从来没有和杰夫·丹尼尔斯合作过。你从来没有和丹尼斯·霍珀合作过。丹尼斯·霍珀在电影的大部分时间里都是孤身一人。拿着电话。但你知道，我在公交车上注意到的一件事，让我大开眼界，那就是，你知道的，警长和所有的警官都坐在公交车旁边的一个平板拖车上。有所有这些场景，他们只是公交车上发生的事情的背景。
bus. Did those guys just ride next to you for 12 hours a day sometimes? That was crazy in the heat on a flatbed. In the SWAT uniforms or wearing those heavy duty, you know, with the bulletproof vest. Well, you know, stunt guys, you know, stunt guys. I mean, they are just gluttonous for punishment, I guess. I don't know. They're amazing. I mean, and they seem to take great joy in it. I mean, I'm sure they're nice. They go home and they say, I'm never doing this again. But it's not my experience with stunt people. They are always so enthusiastic and ready for action. But they are really phenomenal. I mean, they just always just are so eager to jump into the fray. And God bless them. I mean, we need them. That's for sure. We sure do. But yeah, they are on
那些家伙有时真的要在你旁边坐一2个小时吗？在平板车上的高温中，这太疯狂了。穿着特警制服或者穿着那些重型装备，你知道的，带着防弹背心。嗯，你知道的，特技演员，你知道的，特技演员。我是说，他们大概就是受虐狂吧，我猜。我不知道。他们太了不起了。我是说，而且他们似乎对此乐此不疲。我是说，我确信他们人很好。他们回家后会说，我再也不做这事了。但这并不是我对特技演员的经历。他们总是那么热情，随时准备好投入行动。但他们真的很了不起。我是说，他们总是那么渴望投入到激烈的战斗中。愿上帝保佑他们。我是说，我们需要他们。那是肯定的。我们当然需要。但是，是的，他们在
that flatbed, suffering in the heat. And it was hot, hot, hot, you know, September in California, Southern California. It's hotter than the summer. And it was, yeah, God bless them. It's our hottest month for sure. It's September. I think so too. Yeah. Definitely was that year. Well, you know, Beth, you have been in so many things. And we've talked about a few of them here. I'm personally with my daughter rewatching the Mindy project, and you are hilarious in it. She was like, Mom, please tell Beth how much we love her in the Mindy project. So I said I would. Oh, tell me, thank you so much. Yes. But we are curious, what do you get recognized the most for? Is there a character that people really identify with when you're out in the world? Well, you know, what I
那个平板拖车上，在酷暑中受煎熬。而且天气非常非常热，你知道的，加州的九月，南加州。比夏天还要热。而且确实是，愿上帝保佑他们。九月绝对是我们最热的月份。我也这么觉得。是的。那一年绝对是。好吧，你知道的，贝丝，你参演过那么多作品。我们在这里也聊过其中的几部。我个人正和女儿一起重温《明迪烦事多》，你在里面太搞笑了。她当时说，妈妈，请告诉贝丝我们有多喜欢她在《明迪烦事多》里的表现。所以我答应过她会说。哦，告诉我，太谢谢你了。是的。但我们很好奇，你因什么而最广为人知？当你走在世界各地时，有没有哪个角色是人们真正认出你的？好吧，你知道的，我
found is, obviously, it depends on, you know, the fans of which thing, like speed fans and speed. But I will, you're gonna think I'm making it up. But I promise you that the office is at the top, top, tippy top. You know, people love that show so much, they love the dinner party episodes. I mean, a lot of people have called and gotten interviews with me and, you know, Rolling Stone picking it as the top comedic episode in the first 10 years of this century or something. I know y'all know all this, but it is extremely popular show. Y'all are much, much beloved. I mean, you truly are. And I know for a fact, because you're not around. They have no reason to tell me how much they love, love you. And they do, they just do. Well, we were so lucky to have you on the office,
发现的是，显然，这取决于，你知道的，不同作品的粉丝，比如《生死时速》的粉丝和《生死时速》。但我向你保证，你会觉得我是编的。但我向你保证，《办公室》绝对排在最顶端、最顶端、最顶端。你知道的，人们太喜欢那部剧了，他们太喜欢“晚宴”那一集了。我是说，很多人打电话并对进行了采访，你知道的，滚石杂志将其评为本世纪前十年中最佳喜剧剧集之类的。我知道你们都知道这一切，但这是一部极受欢迎的剧集。你们受到的喜爱实在是太多太多了。我是说，真的非常多。而且我知道这是事实，因为你并不在场。他们没有任何理由向我表达他们有多么爱、多么爱你们。而他们确实如此，他们就是这样。好吧，我们能邀请你来《办公室》真是太幸运了，
and we're so lucky that you joined us today to talk about speed. Thank you for coming and nerding out with us. Beth, we were just hanging on your every word. Beth, I love you both so much. I think you're fabulous. And I love your podcast. And I'm gonna root for the Broadway fantasy dream come true, which will happen. And I'm gonna root for you with, I don't know about the gardening and hummingbirds. You can come over and garden and hummingbird with me. I got a lot of I would love that. Beth, I'm not even kidding. I will come over. She's going to be at your house tomorrow. If there's a hummingbird, Angela is there. Trust me. I mean, I'm not kidding. We have all drought resistant native plants in the front and the back. It's, it's a hummingbird paradise over here.
而且你能今天加入我们聊聊《生死时速》，我们感到非常幸运。谢谢你来和我们一起极客一把。贝丝，我们刚才简直洗耳恭听你的每一句话。贝丝，我太爱你们两个了。我觉得你们棒极了。我爱你们的播客。我会为百老汇奇幻梦想成真加油的，这一定会发生的。我会为你的，我不知道关于园艺和蜂鸟的事加油。你可以过来和我一起园艺和观蜂鸟。我有很多我非常乐意。贝丝，我真没开玩笑。我会过去的。她明天就会去你家里。如果有蜂鸟，安吉拉就在那里。相信我。我是说，我没开玩笑。我们在前院和后院都有所有耐旱的本土植物。这里，这里简直是蜂鸟的天堂。
We love them. Beth, I have to come over. Angela is more excited about this news than anything you said about speed. I guarantee it. What a delight. Beth, maybe they come over and give me some advice. Cause I really love to pull weeds and grasses stuff, but we need help. It's very bushy. Nobody needs that much bush. That's what she said. All right. Great. Love you, Beth. Thank you. Thank you. Thank you so much. Oh, thank you everybody for going on this journey with us, rewatching speed and listening to our chat with Beth Grant. This was so much fun, Angela. I want to do more movie breakdowns, I think. I know, me too. I had so much fun watching speed over and over and over. And we also want to say a special thank you to Sam and Cassie and Ainsley for
我们太喜欢它们了。贝丝，我一定要过去。安吉拉对这个消息的兴奋程度超过了你关于《生死时速》所说的任何话。我向你保证。太令人高兴了。贝丝，也许她们可以过来给我一些建议。因为我真的很喜欢拔杂草和草之类的，但我们需要帮助。这里太茂盛了。没有人需要这么茂盛的灌木。她就是这么说的。好的。太棒了。爱你，贝丝。谢谢。谢谢。非常感谢。哦，谢谢大家和我们一起踏上这段旅程，重温《生死时速》，并聆听我们与贝丝·格兰特的聊天。这太有趣了，安吉拉。我想做更多电影解析，我觉得。我知道，我也是。一遍又一遍地看《生死时速》，我玩得太开心了。我们还要特别感谢山姆、卡西和艾因斯利
chipping in and working extra hard to make this episode a huge success. We just love our team so much. We also want to tell you guys that today over at OfficeLadies.com, we are launching a few fun new merch items for spring and summer. You got to check it out. Super, super cute stuff. Marissa and Ileana crushed it. Go check it out. And we're bringing back some oldies, but goodies. And by request, we now have the really cute blue. It is your mug, mug available for single purchase. So yeah, fun stuff. Fun stuff. OfficeLadies.com. And we'll be here next week chatting with you. I hope you have a great one. It's all about season eight starting next week. See you then guys. Bye. Thank you for listening to OfficeLadies. OfficeLadies is produced by Earwolf,
他们为促成这期节目的巨大成功付出了额外的辛勤努力。我们太爱我们的团队了。我们还想告诉大家，今天在 OfficeLadies.com 上，我们为春夏季推出了一些有趣的全新周边商品。你们一定要去看看。超级超级可爱的商品。玛丽莎和伊莱亚娜太棒了。快去看看吧。我们还带回了一些老式但优秀的商品。应大家的要求，现在有了非常可爱蓝色的马克杯，你可以单独购买了。所以，是的，很有趣的东西。很有趣的东西。OfficeLadies.com。我们下周会在这里和大家聊天。希望你们过得愉快。从下周开始将全部围绕第八季展开。到时候见，各位。再见。感谢收听 OfficeLadies。《办公室女士》由 Earwolf 制作，
Jenna Fisher and Angela Kinsey. Our show is executive produced by Cody Fisher. Our producer is Cassie Jerkins. Our sound engineer is Sam Kieffer. And our associate producer is Ainsley Bubbicoke. Our theme song is Rubber Tree by Creed Bratton. For ad-free versions of OfficeLadies, go to StitcherPremium.com. For a free one month trial of Stitcher Premium, use code, Office. There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.
詹娜·费舍尔和安吉拉·金西。我们的节目由科迪·费舍尔执行制作。我们的制作人是卡西·杰金斯。我们的音响工程师是山姆·基弗。我们的副制作人是艾因斯利·巴比科克。我们的主题曲是克里·布拉顿的《Rubber Tree》。要收听无广告版本的《办公室女士》，请访问 StitcherPremium.com。要免费试用 Stitcher Premium 一个月，请使用代码 Office。本集目前还没有评论。点击字幕中的任意句子即可发表评论。